alors 10 - 22 range et a longtemps été
une des princesses de la jet set alors
en faire une interview jet set moi c'est
vrai qu'à son dernier anniversaire il a
fallu se mettre à plusieurs pour aider
regina souffler son gâteau va jamais été
invité moi c'est vrai que massimo gargia
été l'amant de marie-antoinette grands
pas beaucoup c'est vrai qu'en fait
l'abbé pierre et bourrés de thunes qu'il
a 160 mètres carrés dans le 16ème qui
passe sa vie dans les soirées mondaines
du bar les colocs
c'est vrai que le dalaï lama a des parts
dans le buddha bar c'est pas sans tripes
et c'est vrai mais ça tu pourrais me
répondre avec steevy refuse de signer
des autographes par respect pour
l'orthographe